[Music]
in Apple to the rescue news gorgeous
submitted by sip on my shrimp daddy oh
oh yeah yeah yeah sip on my shrimp sells
a little shrimp daddy I know but do you
understand about sipping on a shrimp
sounds a little weird yeah it's [ __ ]
sexy yeah
it's delicious yeah you're just a virgin
cocktail that's all me sipping but you
don't need to sit back no she's talking
about [ __ ] now yeah Oh cocktails jeah if
your cocktail is a shrimp I feel bad for
you just [ __ ] read the tongue man's
Apple watch was credited for saving his
life what's the what's their like you
need this with so we not old lady falls
like help I felt yeah well kind of
hashtag not sponsored cuz this is gonna
sell you guys so so a guy he was it was
an older dude biking he's riding his
bicycle in kind of a rural area cuz you
know those cyclists they just be like 20
miles there's no big deal I'm Lance
Armstrong and he's in a rural area and
he falls and I guess it was a really
hard fall they've actually got a picture
of like how damaged his watch was so you
can tell it was really impact he's
looking what's his body look like you
know we know know well that you can
actually see the hospital band in the
photo
so he falls and it immediately alerts an
emergency services yeah it's a Glick
hard impact fall detected and it sent
his location Arkansas Sicilian trilogy
yeah which is like low-key pretty crazy
so then also because his son was the
emergency contact his son got a text
message with the location and it says
emergency SOS Bob Burdette called
emergency services from this approximate
location after Apple watch detected a
hard fall so it called it like for us
accidentally drop your Washington step
on it by accident I had better safe -
sorry girl and it says you're receiving
this message because bob has listed you
as an emergency contact so it told them
where is it
there is like that you know 911 on the
way I'm gonna get my mom's one dude
right well it actually it actually is
pretty interesting so it so like it's in
him hella updates because first he got
sent to one Medical Center in Washington
and then they sent him to another one
and like he had gone to the first
location but then the Apple watch sent
him another Texan was like your father
husband moved to this location it's a
new feature because I've never do it I
only and and does Apple watch know if
the Apple watch didn't get impacted but
let's say you fall on your hip
could it tell bro I still want it cuz
obviously I think so there's other
safety features to which I think this is
really cool it says the US doctor
recently saved a person's life by using
Apple watch series for on his wrist to
detect a natural fibrillation at a
restaurant which is I forget a stroke
yeah kind of like or the fibrillation
like there's the blood wasn't flowing as
well as it should have been and it was
detected through his watch and then
another one it's like an Apple watch
user in the UK was recently alerted
about his low heart rate by the device
it revealed a serious heart condition
that ultimately resulted in a surgery
early to fix the problem so tells you
you're having a heart attack that's
gonna be so soon imagine we get like
chips on our wrists and they'll be able
to tell you like you got you're trying
to go through a breakup and it's like
you're pregnant whoa
they gotta be working on that now Joe we
got it advanced so I'm trying to get
rich I know Joe's trying to get rid of
you know the vas are trying to get rich
I would love to be poor the rest of my
life I mean the dead serious bra look
cycling though is super serious like
I've been riding a little bit and all my
friends ride a ton and they all like you
just said you don't have any friends
okay people I know people I know they
like even though young dudes like my age
or whatever they'll wear like just a
wristband with an emergency contact on
it because it's so common people eat
[ __ ] damn I can't watch someone has to
find your Bosley your hopefully you're
on a bike path or something and I think
that's why because like at least where
I'm from we have a really popular bike
path that it's only bikes and walkers no
cars and you're kind of on the river so
you're kinda in nature but it's super
coming I had two friends dads
eat it pretty bad have to go to hospital
then why do they do that kind of sport
yeah yeah it mean well my stuff that
actually had a really bad cycling
accident too like I hear a never liked a
traffic cone
something but it I can't even say it
because my honestly like hey yeah what's
up bad happen but it's not real bad and
have input like and it was I know it was
super bad because like I didn't visit
handling I was busy I don't know but
they said that they went to visit him
and like hit like tubes and [ __ ] coming
out of them and it's like really scary
like you start the whole ass you know
you're going 1520 miles per hour and
then you hit like a little gravel or
everything mmm the watch I don't know
everything one yeah we're gonna have sex
we're gonna [ __ ] hook up with some
buddies cuz they you got AIDS yeah what
if you could skate away and you know
what they have yeah in like market time
before laundry eggs
you broke the we're condom we're like oh
yes we do actually we're done we're done
oh they like fuse if like Apple watches
feuds with some kind of like high-tech
like 23andme yeah well just like
high-tech like health lately they just
start putting ads on WebMD books making
a I so why wouldn't happily medical
stuff you always think you're getting
sick or something it's like maybe that's
nothing for a vitamin A or value need
somebody like no but like you press it
three times the net goes on SOS right
yeah yeah how you're gonna make up some
[ __ ] to get a hologram and they're on
this channel did and like well that's
because you're not funny and don't know
how did you but that the point is to try
to make people understand Wow you went
out you do D do you making this face she
stoned
if you press f5 or f4 or one of those
test it out zoom
I remember the control-alt-delete hold
it down twice I'm a hardcore
hypochondriac so this product works for
me
you guys have health anxiety I do I'm
not that's actually one thing I'm really
good with things I just tell myself like
yeah I ain't getting sick yeah [ __ ]
that's why I don't go away boy yeah I'll
eat a rusty nail and on the aughts yeah
I'm getting tetanus [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah
I haven't been to the doctor in like
five years
yeah I don't like real dogs maybe six I
went to the doctor and I was like I was
105 it's like I have neurological
disease sure and probably some other
stuff so just let's just figure out what
it is and we'll be good and we did all
these tests and I come back a week later
and he was like man you are the
healthiest person that's walking its
I tried to like dude it's my shooting
another psychologist dr. yeah mine is so
bad women will go to the doctor I try to
like be like yeah I think I'm just
having a few problems and I try to like
keep it hush-hush that I'm crazy you
know just be like yeah if you could just
check my urine so I have a my thyroid
just yeah I've never been like you do
blood testing you know if you want to
get deep
oh what the but test I probably need
that shirt doc dude let's catch it now
put the probe in put the probe in
whatever it takes do they really do that
do they grab your balls and make you
cough yeah yeah yeah what is that for
this check your prostate know they get
horny the prostate the butthole is a
thing but I think that's only when
you're like 40 plus ya got the
finger-mabob yeah ask you to cough I did
cuz you're ballsy not a doctor
really yeah your balls go up when you
call if I was like standing there if I
was sitting there holding a man's balls
with my finger in his ass and I had to
tell them to make sure that everything's
okay in my like fantasy nurse cosplay
all right that one stays at home I feel
like there's got to be like a couple of
other examples where this stuff kind of
happened
I thought be [ __ ] wait by this behind
your friends like like thing that we
have on our phone and chicks like my mom
travels from East LA all the way to our
neighborhood and it took about like a
30-mile about 30 miles yeah yeah I Drive
for her and it just scares me because
her visions not that good and she
refused stay with us so she leaves that
nice along waiters are nuts I get to see
like where she is just in case like she
was in texted Michigan home she gets
home or whatever yeah and it's good like
teenagers you see it going to the casino
that's a good idea when my mom gets old
her problem I'll probably like like
actually put locations on just cause
like I do make sure like she's good you
know like if she's in one spot for too
long cuz that woman just doesn't quit
man she just keeps [ __ ] gone if she's
in one spot for too long and be like
look hold on
yeah or like what if you're like family
member goes missing and there's like a
kidnapper and they think you're never
gonna find out in [ __ ] location
services are on yeah go get my mom I do
think the watch is cool I never I always
thought those watches were done you know
I don't know if it does that but now we
go home and see if it does yeah dude you
got to I can see Bureau says that is the
older generation I never upgraded it cuz
I just felt like what's the point what
what does it do so you could talk in it
yeah yeah I mean it's not anything crazy
it just looks really cool yeah but you
can see text you can send text from
there like you can like touch and be
like hey I'll call you back Oh like you
talk Texan yeah yeah that you can answer
phone call like you talk to your friends
like this yeah well you Star Trek [ __ ]
I'm the guy that goes to speaker bar
that I Bart [ __ ] the whole body no
you can talk like with your arm down
yeah so you could just walk around and
talk like this it's no TV it tracks like
if you're sitting for too long it'll
tell you to stand up and stretch your
heart rate it is cool that they mix and
help stuff considering how [ __ ] up us
dude I'm trying to think if like in the
future because I never would have
imagined having this little tiny screen
that I was content with like looking
through for hours
imagine if like the watch they get
projects like a screen but would you be
comfortable in bed being like this like
I have a [ __ ] element to like rested
on something no I don't find a way don't
find a way to turn light or something
like just an armrest or like what's the
movie Minority Report the whole computer
the whole computer is the screen you're
moving it around and you're cool I'm
like I'm sure we're right there yeah
well yeah like Apple screens the fact
you like touch and slide and ah yes
close that was like pretty much y'all
remember Google glass that [ __ ] was
stupid
[Music]
[Music]